all right so let's talk about Isis
everyone is constantly talking about
Isis they are the Islamic state in Syria
there in Iraq some people call the
Islamic state in the Levant some people
call them is which is just the Islamic
state and basically they're kind of
controlling and taking pieces of Syria
and Iraq they're on the Turkish border
they're fighting with the Kurds it is a
big freaking mess Lebanon could go down
Jordan could get involved we are now
doing airstrikes I'm giving you a very
Cliff Notes version of what's happening
seems like all these countries on their
borders like Saudi Arabia and Turkey
what are what are they doing with
everyone always yells at America we get
in everybody's business but it doesn't
seem like anyone else wants to help ever
so sometimes we got to I guess maybe or
is it our military-industrial complex
that always is pushing the agenda to
make these things happen I don't know
but I wanted to talk about Isis because
it seems to me what we're doing is not
working so we're dropping a couple bombs
on them
we're probably killing playing innocent
people we don't know that we're really
helping helping I heard that the city
that's on the border of Syria and Turkey
kobani
it sounds like Isis took it even though
we were helping the Kurds bomb it maybe
Turkey was kind of helping it's a big
freakin mess that's my point it was
making me think maybe bombs aren't the
way to go now Isis of course got
everybody freaked out because of the
beheadings right it was the beheadings
these beheading videos which there are
plenty of we talked a lot about on the
show and they're beheading people and
that gets everyone freaking and that was
making me think well maybe better than
beheading would be if Isis if these guys
got head because isn't getting head
really better than beheading I get it
they like behead it they like it an
infidel comes by you know you chop off
his head you feel good about it you feel
like you've done a day's work and all
that that's fine beheading but getting
head you'll find me somebody that
doesn't like getting head and I you
can't I know that you cannot find me
someone that does like getting it
everyone likes getting head and I would
guarantee you if these Isis guys were
getting more head they wouldn't be
beheaded so now when a bomb blows up
your house and your family gets killed
you're gonna be upset but if you're
getting head even while that's happening
you're gonna be slightly happier and a
happier terrorist is a more pleasant
terrorist and then once they get head
then who knows what they'll want to do
you never know
starts with the head so let's get some
head right let's get head and let's get
off beheadings it's a good slogan get
head get off the headaches